Please join me and warmly welcoming
to Google Brendan Nyhan and Dj flame.
Well,
thank you Laura for organizing this and
thanks to all of you for being here.
It's super exciting to
be here and to talk, um,
talk with you all about misinformation
today. Um, so our plan is,
I'm going to talk, uh, first, uh,
that's the top half of the slide here
about the political system today and why,
um, different aspects of American
politics today are conducive to creating
misperceptions that influence people's
attitudes and behaviors and often persist
for a long period despite the
provision of accurate information.
So I'm going to talk about that first.
Um,
and then I'm going to turn it over to
Brendan who's going to talk about it a
little bit more specifically about the
role of fake news and fake news in 2016
in particular, does a roadmap
of, of my part of the talk.
Today I'm going to begin by talking about
some contextual elements in American
politics that are conducive to
misinformation as I mentioned. Um,
I'll then give some examples to give
you a sense of the extent of partisan
differences in factual
beliefs about politics. Um,
I'll talk about some institutional
responses that we've seen, uh,
to misinformation mostly
in the United States. Um,
and then I'll outline some challenges
and opportunities moving forward. Um,
so to begin with the
contextual discussion, um,
I think any discussion of
American politics today has
to start by acknowledging
that the huge and really historic levels
of partisan polarization that we see at
the elite level in the United States.
Um,
so this is a plot showing a roll call
ideology spores in Congress for members of
the Democratic Party, uh, in the
Republican Party over time. Um,
so higher scores here are more liberal
voting records in Congress and lower
scores on the y axis are more
conservative records. Um,
and as you can see by this
increasing divergence over time,
we have a dramatic polarization in
ideology among political elites.
That is to say Democrats are becoming
more and more liberal in their roll call.
Voting, Republicans becoming
more and more conservative,
and there's just less area of ideological
agreement at the elite level. Um,
which as we'll see,
has important implications for
how partisans in the mass public,
how ordinary Democrats and Republicans a
form opinions and factual beliefs about
politics. Um, another, uh,
really important institutional change
that we've seen in recent in recent
decades is the resurgence
of partisan media. Um,
so we now see explicitly ideological
and sometimes partisan outlets providing
information. Um, this is important
for a huge number of reasons,
but I'll focus just on one, it's
relevant for the discussion today. Um,
and that is that when you have a highly
partisan, highly fragmented media system,
um,
what you have is you have people
watching certain channels and coming away
watching different of channels and
coming away with fundamentally different
understandings of the same issue or event.
Okay.
So if we think about events that are in
the news today and how the same event is
covered by Sean Hannity on Fox, for
example, in Rachael Maddow on MSNBC,
um, they might be covering
the same sort of larger story,
like the potential link between
the Trump campaign and Russia,
but they cover it from very,
very different angles.
And so partisan viewers of each network
come away with very different factual
understandings of the same issue. Um,
this is, uh, this is a relatively new,
um, aspect of, of the media system,
right? So, um, up until recent decades,
we had a relatively homogeneous media
system with a small number of channels,
right? Not as much partisan choice.
And that's important because, uh,
it led to the opposite of
what we have today, right?
People had a smaller selection of,
uh,
news channels to watch and they came
away with the same basic set of facts,
which we increasingly no
longer no longer half. Now,
one important result of this resurgence
in partisan media and increase in
partisanship and the mass public is
a large increase in what we political
scientists call an affective polarization.
Um,
so AFX rates just simply
how you feel about a certain
group, usually an outgroup.
Um, so there are lots of different ways
of measuring an affective polarization in
politics. Um, this is one of the
more clever ones on the top here.
This shows the trend in the percent of
people who would be upset if a member of
their immediate family married a member
of the other political party. Um,
there are lots of measures
of effect of polarization,
but this is one of the more
interesting ones I think. Um,
and you see the pretty
steady linear linear increase
over the time series on the
x axis and his huge spike
around 2008, 2009. Okay.
I'm sorry.
Um,
the line might be smooth. I'm not,
I'm not sure. These are my data. Yeah,
I think there's a lowest
smoother on the line.
Another sort of more straight forward,
a more straightforward measure of this,
right, is just how do you
feel sort of a zero to 100.
Do you feel cool toward the opposing
party or warm toward the opposing party?
And we see pretty steady decreases among,
uh,
people across the partisan spectrum in
terms of how they feel about members of
the opposing the opposing party.
And that that negative trend
is especially dramatic, right?
Among strong Democrats and
strong Republicans. Um, now
that's important, right?
Because people who tend to be
strongly partisan participate more,
they're more likely to vote, they're more
likely to contact members of Congress.
And so those, um, highly
politically active,
influential people are more and more as
effectively polarized towards members
the other party. Okay. Um,
and these are some of the,
these are some of the
contextual changes in,
in the US political system in recent
years that have led to really dramatic
partisan differences in factual
beliefs. Okay. So I, um,
I'm showing some examples here that
I think many of us will recognize,
but I think the data, I'm
really help us understand, uh,
how much factual polarization we've seen
on these issues over time. Um, which is,
uh, which is, uh, um, that
time trend often gets, often
gets lost, right. Um, in,
in, in media coverage. Um, and so we see
partisan differences in factual beliefs.
About major social and
economic problems, like, uh,
beliefs about the cause of global
warming. Um, and, and lots of,
lots of other, a really hugely
influential policy issues. Um,
so this is just showing,
right?
The percent of people who believe that
the rise of the Earth's temperature is
due mostly to human activity among
Democrats, Republicans and independents.
And you see this increasing
divergence over time. Okay.
Um, we also see these partisan differences
in factual beliefs on the content of
major legislation, right? Like the
affordable care act or tax reform.
And it's being debated now, or Aca
repeal that's being debated now. Um,
so this is a really a really cool a graph
from a paper that Brendan Road in 2010
which I often a steal for talks like this.
Um,
so this shows the percent of people
who believe in the left panel, um,
that the Clinton healthcare
reform proposal in the
early 1990s would result in
people losing their choice of
doctor. Um, and it shows the belly,
it shows belief in that, in that claim
by different partisan groups, right?
Democrats and Blue Republicans
and red independence in green. Um,
and what's even more interesting here,
and maybe a little bit depressing, right?
It's,
you'll notice there are two,
there are two points for
each party corresponding, uh,
down here on the x axis to people who
report that they have, um, uh, two,
it's too early or they don't know very
much about the plan versus partisans who
say they have a really good
understanding of the plan.
So these are people who self report that
they know a lot about the plan and we
see that the more people think they know,
the more misinformed they
actually are in some cases, right?
So we see huge partisan disagreement
among partisans who claim to have a really
good factual understanding
of these issues. Um, and we
see a similar pattern, uh,
about the death panel claim and the
affordable care act in 2009 on the right
side. Okay. Um, this is perhaps
the most famous example, right,
of partisan differences in factual beliefs
in recent years. This is the shows,
right? Differences in the belief
that Barack Obama was not born.
It was or was not born in the United
States. Uh, not surprisingly, right? Huge,
huge differences here. Okay. Um,
now, so we have, we have these,
uh,
this partisan disagreement and on all
these different factors that play a large
role in policy debates.
Um,
and we've seen a lot of institutional
responses to this and attempts to correct
misperceptions and bring,
bring partisans together and sort of
their factual understanding of politics.
I'm the first one that I think
is really important, right,
is the rise of political fact checking.
Um,
so there's this nice new report out by
the Duke reporters' lab that shows that
tracks the trend and the growth of fact
checking or for the past 10 or so years,
and we've seen about 150% explosion
in fact checkers across, um,
across the globe in the last three years
in response to this, uh, this upsurge in,
in misinformation and democracies
across the world. Right?
Um, really a related point, right? We've
seen an uptick in watchdog journalism.
So even as, um, a lot
of newspapers, right,
face financial burdens and they're
shrinking their news teams,
we've seen a lot of papers sort of re uh,
recalibrate their,
their focus and focus a lot more on,
um,
investigative watchdog style journalism.
Um, so these are some headlines from,
from very recent months,
right,
about fact checking claims made by
Hillary Clinton and Donald Trump played a
large role, uh, in, in the campaign
and still play a large role today.
Okay. Um, now of course,
there are still a lot of challenges ahead
for fact checkers and other people who
seek to mitigate
misinformation in politics. Um,
the first is declining trust in media
over time, right? So people, uh,
people,
uh,
self reported trust in media has declined
pretty steadily in recent decades.
Um, it doesn't help when
you have a prominent members
of both parties, frankly,
who regularly make a
arguments in media media,
can't be trusted and can't be,
can't be trusted to adjudicate these
factual disputes that we see. Okay.
Um,
there's also this,
this echo chamber problem which Brendan's
going to talk about in a moment.
And this is the idea that,
um,
given that explosion and media choice
that I talked about in the beginning, um,
people sometimes a expose themselves to
information selectively. That is to say,
Democrats for instance, might watch
MSNBC or read the Huffington Post.
Republicans might watch box or read
Breitbart. Um, you know, there's a lot of,
uh,
new research with really cool data that
you're going to hear about in a second,
uh, tracking the extent of this and
who actually engages in this. Um,
but this is, this is a
challenge to be sure. Um,
another, another sort of disclaimer
that I just want to give before I,
before I conclude is that a lot of the
examples that I've focused on in the talk
are highly partisan facts,
right?
By definition that are at the center of
partisan disagreement. And you might say,
Oh, well, you know,
you're always going to see partisan
disagreement on these sorts of issues.
Perhaps that's not super troubling.
Um,
but I want to highlight that
we see a lot of misperceptions,
factual misperceptions that are widely
held by members of both parties. Okay.
It means exist on really important issues
like foreign aid. This is one example.
Um,
uh,
people tend to vastly overestimate the
size of outgroups like immigrants and
minority groups in general. Um, there,
there are huge misperceptions
about, uh, tax policy,
which is being debated right now,
right about the percent of the budget
that goes to various things like,
like foreign aid, uh, defense and
that sort of thing. Um, so it's,
it's not just that we see,
um,
partisan disagreement on these
highly charged issues, right?
We see them broadly across lots of
different issues that are coming up. Um,
now there are of course opportunities to,
to address some of this.
Um, so I'll just, I'll just highlight
two, uh, in closing here. Um,
so the first potentially useful
strategy for practitioners, right,
who were interested in combating this
information made it's to call people out,
which is largely what fact checkers do
and try to increase the reputational
costs of false statements.
Um,
so if politicians feel that they have to
pay a price when they make an accurate
statements,
uh,
we can try to attack this sort of supply
side of misinformation rather than
focusing on what happens sort of post,
uh,
post fall statement and
correcting people's misperceptions
after they hold them.
Um,
this is sort of the fact checking model,
but I want to emphasize that of
course you don't have to be in sort of
institutionalized fact checking
organization to do this. Um, uh,
uh, tools, uh, at places like
Google and Facebook and elsewhere.
We've made efforts at flagging
false claims at the point of,
at the point of communication. Try this
the same, the same strategy, right? Um,
in the second,
the second opportunity I want to
highlight is there a lot of really highly
credible sources, um, that can, uh,
combat miss misperceptions even when
they're highly polarized along political
lines. Um, one, uh, situation,
which misperceptions are often a little
bit easier to correct a is when you can
get a partisan or ideological actors
speaking against his or her own self
interest, that's often highly persuasive,
right? There are lots of experiments,
for instance, that show
that if you can get, um,
a Republican to combat the plane,
that there were death panels
in the affordable care act,
that that's a much more persuasive Q.
Then if you can get somebody who is just
totally in support of the affordable
care act for instance to do that. And
there are lots of other examples. Um,
and finally,
unexpected sources are often really
highly persuasive in correcting this
perception. So there's a neat
new paper that shows, uh,
that when corrected information about
the human causes of global warming is
provided by military organizations or
defense related entities as opposed to
scientists.
It's just a more surprising source
and it sort of disarms people and has,
it has a much more powerful impact.
Um,
so these are just two opportunities that
I wanted to flag that have sort of come
up in recent research. There are certainly
others. Um, uh, but with that I'll,
I'll uh,
turn it over to Brendan.
All right.
So what I want to do now is turn more
specifically to the 2016 election that
what Djs don't.
Hopefully it's given you an overview
of why we might be especially concerned
about people's vulnerability to miss
perceptions in the partisan age that we
live in, in this country. Um,
so I'm going to talk specifically about
the 2016 election focusing on fake news.
But you should of course think of that.
And I'm going to say what I mean
by fake news in a moment, but,
but you should think of that as a
subset of the larger problem with
misinformation.
The DJ has been talking about fake news
is one particular manifestation of the
ways in which people's
political commitments can
influence what they choose to
believe is true in the information they
consume. But it's hardly the only one.
And in some ways it's important to
maybe overstated as I'll talk about the
concern that a lot of people have had
have expressed since the election is
weather. Uh, people are not just
living in an echo chambers of opinion,
but echo chambers of fact,
right? In other words,
it's not just that we tend to interact
both online and off with people who share
our political commitments,
but that we may actually be only hearing
from or disproportionately hearing from
people who share our same
understanding of the world. Right?
And that's not just from
your social counterparts,
but from the information you consume. And
that's very worrisome to people, right?
Even if we disagree about opinions,
uh, about what we should do, uh,
you'd like to think that we could have
a debate as a democracy based on some
shared set of facts. And the fear that's
come out of this election of course,
is that that's no longer the case.
So I don't want to talk about, um,
fake news in 2016 election in the context
of that question and help you try to
get you, give you some intuition on
how you might think about that problem.
Okay.
So this is my technical analysis of the
state of a factual discourses in the
2016 election. Right? If it seemed
terrible to you, it was terrible.
We studied this full time
and, uh, we agree. I mean,
there's no systematic way to say how
factual a political debate was over time.
Historically, there's no agreed
upon set of standards. Uh,
but I think it's fair to say
a qualitative judgment, uh,
is that this election was
especially poor. Okay. Um,
the reason for that starts
with the unprecedented level
of elite misinformation
that came out during this
campaign. There's no way around
that fact. Okay. And the,
you know,
both candidates obviously said many
things that were false or unsupported.
One of them said that said it with
historic frequency and was his,
it was unprecedented,
his unwillingness to retract or correct
the record when a misstatement was made.
Okay.
We'll set that aside.
The question of interest for
us today though, you know,
in the second part of the talk
is what happened with fake news.
So here are five of the most widely
shared fake news stories of the 2016
campaign according to a sharing data
from Facebook compiled by Craig Silverman
at buzzfeed.
Okay.
And you can see that they're often
quite outlandish and over the top right.
So Pope Francis Endorses Donald Trump.
Hillary Clinton is disqualified from
office. Hillary sold weapons to isis. Um,
and the heel FBI agent involved in the
email investigation is dead in a murder
suicide. Okay. Um, but there are
many, many more cases like this.
There's a whole industry of fake news
that sprung up during the campaign.
Okay. Um, to give you a sense
of the magnitude of this,
silvermen found that the most
shared fake news stories,
according to the public Facebook
sharing data, of course,
the Facebook data science team knows
more about this than than I do.
But I can tell you from the
public sharing data that he,
he found the most shared fake news stories
were shared more often than the most
shared mainstream news stories in
that period before the election. Now,
that doesn't mean that the audience
were fake news was greater. Okay.
Because there were a few viral hits
and a lot of duds in the fake news,
uh, in the set of fake news
articles that were published, right?
So it's still the case that the
mainstream media was far more, uh,
widely shared during that period.
But it does suggest how,
uh,
quickly these kinds of stories can
reach a very large audience. Right?
So if you imagine this many million
shares happening on Facebook and how many
times people are at least
passing by the headline,
if not necessarily reading the
article, you know, there's,
these seem to have been very widespread,
right?
And many of you probably saw these at
some point during the election campaign.
Okay, now it's hard to say
exactly how many, again,
the Facebook data science
team knows I don't,
but we can try to get answered this
question in some different ways.
So silvermen and his colleague at
buzzfeed went back and asked people,
did you remember seeing or hearing
about this story in the last few weeks?
And they find somewhere
between approximately 10 and
20% of Americans said they
did. This is a survey fielded
very soon after the election.
Now the problem with this is you're
probably thinking is, of course,
it's hard to remember every new
story I saw. And that's true. Okay.
So what we'd really like to have is who
click through and who read this using
behavioral data rather than a self
reported recall measure like this, right?
Some of these people may be falsely
believing they saw a story and they never
actually saw it and vice versa.
Okay.
But it gives you a sense of
the approximate magnitude.
And what they did find was among those
folks who said they had seen or heard
about these stories that somewhere
around two thirds to for fis,
uh, believe that they, these
stories were accurate. Okay.
So it seems like there was a nontrivial
number of Americans who encounter these
stories,
remembered them and believe them.
Okay.
So similar data here, uh, from two
economists, uh, Al Cotton Gins,
Carol,
it's a little bit small on the slide.
The grouping of interests is in
the middle portion of the y axis.
The false stories where they asked people
again, um, do you think this was true?
And they showed them a bunch of false
headlines as well as some true ones and
simple CBO headlines they made up.
And what you can see as again around 10
and 20% of Americans for any given fake
news headline said they
believed it was true.
A very large number of those said they
didn't know or they weren't sure, right.
Often 50% of the public or more,
which is troubling if you look at what
the content of these sorts of fake news
headlines was.
For example,
the pizzagate conspiracy
theory that Hillary Clinton
is involved in a pedophilia
ring being run out of a pizza
parlor in Washington DC, right?
So somewhere around, if you look at
the, the line there that, you know,
40 to 50% of Americans are saying
either that's true or they're not sure,
right? So we'd really like the answer
to be no, right. That it's false. Okay.
Um, so these things can, again, even
for those people who don't believe them,
they raise questions and
doubts, potentially there
may be worrisome, right? Um,
people may be vulnerable to,
um,
at least calling into question things
that we wouldn't like to be called into
question because they are in fact falls.
So
why did this happen?
Okay.
So I want to just identify two factors
you might think about and it's obviously
relevant to how people interact with
Google in its various forms, right?
Why were vulnerable to this,
right?
The first is the choice of
the information we consume,
which is often called selective exposure.
That in some context,
in some circumstances we pick and choose
the information we consume according to
the extent to which is consistent
with our political preferences. Okay.
That's going to vary depending on the
context you're in and the motivation you
have to seek out that sort of information
as I'll show you in his Dj suggested.
It's not universal,
but it's very much a threat,
especially in the context,
uh,
of something like a campaign
when people's political, uh,
emotions are at a fever
pitch, right? That was as,
as passionate as po about
politics as people get.
And that was a time when people might be
especially interested in something that
seemed to confirm how they felt about
a candidate or to disconfirm something
they'd like to hear.
Just the second problem is what's called
directionally motivated reasoning.
So all of those factors that are
causing people to feel so strongly about
politics and become so polarized me
that when we encounter that information,
our directional preferences about what's
true often override our motivation to
hold an accurate belief, right? The
side we'd like to be a correct, right?
We often conclude they have the
stronger argument, they have,
the more persuasive claim. Okay.
Even when that's not the case.
So this raises a real challenge for fact
checkers or for information providers
of any sort, including,
uh, everyone here. Right?
So the first question you might think
about in terms of fact checking as a
potential response to fake
news and misinformation more
generally is in terms of
selective exposure, do people
read them? Right? And it's
not just a, it's, you know,
so the fact checkers will tell you and I,
I should say,
I know the fact checkers and they're
great and they're, they weren't very hard.
Okay.
And they do have very large audiences
now compared to where they were not very
long ago.
But what you might think about is are
the right people reading fact checks and
are they reading fact checks
of the right claims? Right?
It may be the case that the people reading
fact checks are the not necessarily
the ones who are holding the given
misperception and question, right?
And it might even be the case
that you read fact checks,
but you read the fact check of the claim
by the other side that you don't want
it to be true, right? So it's not
just, it's not good enough to say,
well fact checks are out there
and some people were reading them.
You really want to think about targeting
is the person who is mind you think
could be changed by the fact check
being reached by that fact check. Okay.
The problem with fact checking,
and I'm sure those of you who've worked
with surfacing fact checks in Google
have thought about this problem is that
everyone thinks everyone else needs them,
right? We don't think we need them
ourselves. We think, well, you know, I, I,
I'm well informed with those other people.
They really should read the
fact checks more. Right?
And that's been an obstacle to all sorts
of technological solutions to this,
right?
This is something where the demand among
the people we like to read the fact
checks is an often as strong as we'd like.
Okay.
And even if they do happen to read
the fact check or encounter it,
will they find it persuasive?
That's the next question. Right?
So even if we overcome
selective exposure and they, uh,
choose to consume that piece of
information, is it persuasive to them?
Do they evaluate that factcheck and
conclude, okay, this, this claim, uh,
I thought was true, was
actually false. Right?
And that's where we were directly
motivated reasoning would get in a way,
when you think about fake
news in 2016 election, though,
I want to encourage you to go beyond
the psychological factors we've been
talking about.
And think about the supply side is Dj
alluded to not just the demand side. Okay?
Human psychology isn't going to change.
All right?
Political scientists can tell you
polarization is not going away. Okay?
So for both of those reasons,
I'm trying to change the extent to which
people engage in selective exposure.
Indirection of motivated reasoning
is going to be very difficult. Okay.
There may be ways to mitigate it on the
margin and Dj gave you some suggestions
of how we might do that, but we also have
to think about the supply side. Okay.
There's a reason that people
enter this market, right?
There were entrepreneurs who are
attracted to this market. You've all read,
I assume of the mat about the Macedonian
teenagers who across the Ocean said I
can buy a new guitar if I write fake
news stories for American audiences and
sell and sell ads against them. Right. Um,
so the financial incentives
played a really big role here.
The partisanship that people had made
it financially attractive to create
content that would attract audiences
you could sell ads against. Right?
So the ad that works are playing
an important role here. Okay. Um,
the second factor is really important is,
is, is distribution mechanisms. Right?
And Facebook seems to have play as,
I'll show you some more direct
evidence for this a moment,
but Facebook in particular seems to have
played a key role in distributing fake
news.
Okay.
The reporting we have about the publishers
of fake news is that they would go
see those articles into pro Trump Facebook
groups as a distribution mechanism
and, and people in those groups
would then push them out.
And that was part of how they would get
these stories to a wide distribution.
Okay. So, uh, those
sorts of platforms are,
you know, potentially enabling the spread
of bad information, not just good. Okay.
Um,
and the final factor of course,
is that negative partisanship is DJ
emphasize to you is so powerful now.
It's not just polarization,
it's not just partisanship,
it's how much people don't
like the other side. Right?
And that's creating a demand
for information about why
the other side is bad or
the other side is evil. Why
the other side? And that's,
you should obviously that's terribly
destructive to the kinds of compromise and
living together that we need
for a democracy to work. Okay.
So this is a deep and fundamental problem,
but,
and this is one expression of it that's
especially pernicious because now we're
not only potentially intensifying
that negative partisanship,
but we're misleading people
about the facts as well. Okay.
But not, you know, I,
I suggested you earlier and I want to
give you a little bit more of a sense of
this, that not everyone is engaging
in this all the time, right?
You're probably saying,
well,
I don't go seek out fake news that
conforms to my political viewpoints at all
times. And that's probably true. Okay.
So this is data from my
coauthor Andy guests at Nyu.
I'm looking at a near representative
sample of Americans who've provided an
anonymous who provided consent for, uh,
sharing their online web traffic data.
Okay?
And there's two plots here.
I'm going to talk you through
the differences between them.
What he's doing is he's looking at the
estimated slant of the media outlets they
visit in terms of websites.
Okay.
And the slant estimate comes from the
average ideology of the people who share
these sites on Facebook.
Okay? So it's, uh,
it's from an article by some
Facebook data scientists.
So what you can see in the left panel
was that the average person's average
media outlet is quite centers
regardless of party. Okay?
So the average person is not seeking
out a steady diet of skewed Pars and
information. Most people don't
care about politics that much,
especially outside of a campaign
context. This is 2015 data. Okay Boys,
you can see in the right panels that the
distribution at the audience level in
terms of where the overall set
of traffic is going by party,
it looks very different, right?
That's what you're seeing.
That big partisan polarization between,
uh,
the kinds of sites Democrats
go to in the left, in blue,
in the kind of sites it
Republicans go to on the right,
and that there's a smaller set of folks
on both sides of the aisle who are,
who are consuming large amounts of
information disproportionately from
likeminded media outlets.
Okay.
Uh, oh, I'm sure. Yes. From
left to right, daily coast,
the Huffington Post and
the New York Times, CNN,
just to the left of the red spike.
Msn is under the middle.
There's still a remarkable number
of people who go to the, the,
the main portals like MSN and Yahoo.
And then on the right
Fox News and Breitbart.
So, um, I mentioned this to you
earlier about the role of Facebook.
Here's some partial evidence
that's consistent with that.
I might or might not have more information
about this that I could talk to you
in a non record about an a
non-recorded format. Um, the, what,
uh, these economists Alcott against
cofound is that fake news sites were
differentially likely to have
been reached via social media.
Okay. So you can see in the
bottom, in the bottom bar here,
more than 40% of their visits originated
in social media compared to only about
10% for top news sites.
Okay.
So it seems to have been a really
important traffic driver. Um,
search a smaller traffic
driver relative to a top news,
but a nontrivial one,
right? About 22% there.
So in terms of fact checking and its
role in countering fake news, um,
one of the problems was that
no one really expected this.
And so the fact checkers
weren't, uh, on top of it as a,
as a target for fact checking,
and they typically have
focused on elite statements,
statements made by politicians,
party members, right?
The president members of Congress,
people like that.
And the only exception,
you know for the most part was Snopes,
which focuses more on rumors and hoaxes,
which fake news seem to fall more
squarely within. But even still,
I would say that, you know, everyone
was caught off guard by this. Okay.
So now there's going to be more
fact checking and fake news.
I think it's fair to say, and the
question is how effective will it be?
And I just want to raise some questions
that you should think about as you think
about how effective these
kinds of approaches might be.
Okay. Um, the first one is,
I mentioned you earlier,
is that the people who read fake news
may or may not actually see a fact check
of it,
right?
It's entirely possible to have a world
where those are two disjoint sets, okay.
Or ones with very little overlap.
Okay.
And so we should worry a lot about the
extent of which the fact checking of fake
news that's being done right now is
reaching the people we'd like it to reach.
The second point is I would just encourage
you to be very specific about what
you mean by the effects of fake news.
This is something that people talk
about very loosely and I think, uh,
it's often fake news is being used as
it's kind of catch all term for all sorts
of misinformation and people are making
sweeping claims about its effects,
but I don't think are well supported by
the facts. So in the case of fake news,
you'll hear people say fake news
affected the outcome of the election.
I don't think there's any evidence for
that in terms of changing who won. Okay.
Um, it's, it's,
it's very difficult to show that you'd
have to make very strong assumptions that
Alcott and gins, cow
article I mentioned, uh,
walks you through the kinds of assumptions
you'd have to make to get to an
outcome like that. Similarly,
fact checking itself may
not change that many votes.
Right? Even if you've read a
fact, I think of your own life.
If you read a fact check that
change your mind about something,
did it change how you were going to
vote on which party you preferred?
Probably not.
Right?
So we have to be realistic about what
fact checking can and can't accomplish.
Right?
Um,
and then finally I just encourage you
to think about misinformation in general
and not focus on fake news to the
exclusion of this larger problem,
which is a much more systematic one.
Then these particular, you know,
sites that have popped up that are wholly
fake, non journalistic, right? The, the,
the Macedonian teenager version
of fake news. All right.
So I want to conclude with a few,
with a brief discussion to get us moving
towards the Qa and your thoughts about
what to do about this,
uh,
in terms of the policy responses that are
being pursued out there and what might
be effective. Okay. So the first
thing is to think about ad networks.
No one has any constitutional right to
be part of an ad network, right? In fact,
as a company,
you should wish to protect your brand
from any association with these terrible
misleading sites.
Okay.
So it seems as though ad networks are
starting to crack down and who has,
who is allowed to be a member of them
and they're starting to even be white
listing policies put into place, right?
So then rather than stripping out, uh,
the worst sites, they're selectively
adding the best. Okay. Um,
so I think that's a promising approach
that's also going to be driven by the
advertisers who are increasingly worried
about what their ad is showing that
what content or ad is showing up against.
Obviously Youtube is dealing with
this on a massive scale right now.
Second, thinking about the
algorithm, I know this,
there's probably like 10 to search
people here who don't want to hear my
thoughts on the algorithm,
but let me just say there was an
announcement made that fake news was being
downward in the algorithm and I
think that's appropriate given
the concerns about the quality of
this kind of information. Right?
You were not serving your users well.
If you are surfacing that information up,
uh, it is not high quality.
Right. And then finally,
the most developed response we've seen
has been the fact checking partnership
with the,
uh,
the fact checkers partnership with
Facebook where they're going to identify
stories that have been rated as
false by established fact checkers.
They're going to give you a nudge
first one. You see it. And again,
if you'd like to share it
saying this, just, you know,
this is disputed by this fact
checker in that fact checker. Okay.
And that's a more deliberate kind of
intervention to that provides, uh,
information to people,
but in it,
I think an appropriately hands off way
that keeps Facebook out of the business
of trying to adjudicate
what's true and false. Okay.
Leaves that to the journalist where
that's their core competency. Okay. Um, so
one last point is just simply to say
this is an evolving problem. Okay.
So if you follow the political
debate since the election,
the kinds of misinformation you see
out there, it looks quite different.
The form it's taking, it's
is different. Okay. Um,
there are all these conspiracy
minded folks on Twitter. Uh,
writing and circulating fairly crazy
things I won't get into too much of,
but let me just say that I'm a,
there isn't just an article about
a Harvard University professor,
very famous law professor as well as
the senator who are citing the most, uh,
you know,
non-credible conspiracy sites on the
left to make sweeping unsupported claims
about Trump and Russia.
So this misinformation problem is evolving
and changing and you should be aware
of how rapidly it evolves and avoid the
mistake of fighting the last war. Okay.
So with that note,
we,
we would love your questions and I just
want to say please don't give up. Right.
I remember my, you know, we may not
be able to put out the dumpster fire,
but we can at least like
bring it down a little. Okay.
And it's important not to give into this
temptation to say we're in a post truth
and post facts society and there's
nothing we can do about it.
There is something we can do about it.
We should defend these norms and you
at the platforms Google like Google and
Facebook can in some ways do
more than almost anybody. So, um,
I think we'd love your
questions and thanks very much.
Hi. So, uh, I came to this talk, uh,
part of the reason I came was because
that was a little bit worried about my own
personal bubble that I might be in and
how would I know about this? And uh,
I'm a liberal and I noticed that most
of the fake news stories that you gave
were aim towards Republicans.
So I wanted to know is it the case that
most fake news stories were aimed at
Republicans or can you give some examples
of fake news stories that were aimed
at Democrats during the election?
The fake news was
overwhelmingly pro Trump.
There were only a handful of pro
Clinton fake news stories that took off.
Some people tried it, it wasn't
as successful in the marketplace.
So at least in that particular
format it seemed to not work.
But as I'm suggesting to you,
some of these dubious conspiracy sites
have gotten more traction among Democrats
in the time since the election when
Trump is in office and creates,
he's the kind of scary
opponent who motivates belief
and misinformation the way
Clinton was drinking
campaign. Yeah, I would just,
I would totally concur and I would just
say that it's important to keep in mind
that it's important to keep in mind that
misinformation exist within this larger
political context and the nature
of party competition and who's in,
who's in the White House and
who's in control of Congress.
These are all things that shift over
time and are going to continue to shift
over time. Right? So if we think about
the demand for misinformation about just,
you know, the president for example,
this is the most salient, right?
Political figure in the United
States. Of course, you know, the, the,
the partisan coalitions who are dead,
who are demanding that information is
going to shift over time and you're going
to see the flow and the supply of,
of fake news and misinformation
more generally be responsive to,
to sort of who to to the shift in
conditions that I talked about.
I'm going to hand the mic,
John, who's picking up some
questions from the dory. Sure. Um,
so this is from the London office.
Um,
do you have anything particular to say
about fake science or is it all the same
no matter what the subject? So I've done
research on vaccine misinformation and,
and that's certainly, you know,
Dj mentioned climate change.
So this is certainly something
that's not specific to politics.
It extends the health and science as well.
I in vaccines is a good example where
it's not an ideological or partisan issue
as such.
And misinformation can still be quite
widespread and people can still engage in
selective exposure and are actually
motivated reasoning too. Um,
so I think there's,
there's reason to question in all of
these domains where people have strong
views and about an issue that seems to
implicate some aspect of their identity.
Uh,
there's,
there's a real potential
to have counterproductive
effects or for people to seek
out information that seems to
confirm their views. All right.
So just to give you an
example, um, there is, uh,
a measles outbreak going
on right now in Minnesota,
in the Somali American
community predominantly.
And the story that's been told by our
journalists there is that there was some
children had autism and the parents
didn't know why that wasn't a concept that
we're familiar with and people started
to search and they found their way to
some of the really terrible information
out there and have since been tar.
And as they became more
interested in that,
some folks invited the anti-vaccine
activists who present as misleading and
false science.
Um,
and they've cultivated that to the point
that their vaccination rates from very
low,
um,
and made them vulnerable to
what is now an ongoing outbreak.
And measles is a very dangerous disease.
Explosive. We contagious, right?
So this is a good, it's a good reminder
that misinformation doesn't have to be,
um, partisan and it can have very
immediate and dangerous consequence.
I have a question about, uh, the sort
of the psychology side of the, uh,
the recipients of the fake news.
I know people who love
to be no at all and so,
and they will happily fill in the gaps
in their knowledge as they're explaining
something.
Uh,
I wonder if any investigations be done
about whether they are particularly
vulnerable to, to the
misinformation or, you know,
because they are,
it was like once they've accepted it did,
they're going to tout it
enthusiastically. I actually, I'm,
I'm inferring that they will do that.
I suppose that you should leave it to you.
Um, so the, the closest sort of
individual level factor that,
that I can think about there
that's been studied as, um, there,
there are psychological studies on the
need for need for closure or the need for
certainty. And there's, there's a lot
of variation across people in, in,
in their score on that,
right?
Like some people to your point
need to need to know things.
And need to fill in the blanks. Now to the
extent that those, um, those people are,
are highly partisan, highly
political people. Um,
directionally motivated reasoning, right?
Would suggest that they're going to put,
they're gonna apply their abilities
to forming partisan or ideologically
consistent views. And I think that's that
I could definitely see that happening.
I'm not aware of any studies on sort
of individual the effect of individual
level differences like that. Um, on,
on the propensity to have
misperceptions or something.
I don't know if you would add yeah,
no, that's it. That sounds right. And
I would just say that, um, people,
you know what you were saying about
people kind of filling in the gaps, right?
Another thing you might think about here
is conspiracy theories often have that
function and kind of what you can think
of as a kind of subset of misinformation
or misperceptions. Sorry,
my microphone is off.
You can think of conspiracy theories,
the kind of subset of misinformation or
misperceptions where people who want to
understand what's going on or think they
understand what's going on right now
are filling in gaps. Okay.
So we don't know why, uh,
we don't really understand
why autism happens, right?
The vaccine story provides
a simple explanation, right?
There are chaotic and
conflicting information about
what happened in nine 11.
The inside job miss seems to explain what
happened and you go through the list.
These misperceptions,
we'll often have that flavor of
seeming to provide a compelling simple
explanation for what's going on.
And some people I think do
intuitively gravitate to those.
There's definitely evidence that people
who are predisposed to see the world in
that way will disproportionately
believing conspiracy theories.
Here's another question.
This one's from mountain view.
There been some discussion that the
issue of misinformation is exacerbated by
readers not knowing how to critically
be news and or navigate the overwhelming
nature of the current high choice
media environment. How might
this concern and be relevant to
Google? Okay, that's a good point.
Let me say a couple of things. There's
been a lot of interest in steel action in,
in news and media literacy and I think
educators are thinking about this as an
issue.
Um,
so one of the things Google might be
able to do is support news and media
literacy as a component
of civics education, um,
as something that librarians could teach.
Um,
there's lots of ways in which we might
help equip people to become better
citizens. Right. The
educational approach though is,
is pretty limited in the sense that,
you know,
you're only getting those
younger folks as they,
as they come through the educational
system year by year. Right?
But we have a very large set of adults
who are not in the educational system
anymore and we might think about how we
could reach them more effectively. Um,
I think this is an area where libraries
are probably the most effective vehicle.
We have all these institutions full
of books and people and Librarians are
trying to repurpose themselves as
helping people navigate the world of
information. Right? They don't, we don't
need them to help us find books anymore,
but they want to be information navigator.
So I think there,
there might be opportunities for things
like partnerships. Um, at the same time,
I think we have to think about how to
make it easier for people in the first
place. Right. It, I worry
there's too much. Uh, you know,
and I don't mean to attribute this
to your question, but in general,
out in the world,
there's too much kind of lecturing
people for not being sophisticated.
We need to help them make
better decisions, right? In
a responsible, ethical way.
Well, we don't tell them
we know the right answer.
We're going to in a condescending way,
give it to them, but that we create,
you know,
a kind of information architecture that
helps people make better decisions and
get better information.
Yeah.
And this is where the,
the adjustments to search algorithms and
different tools that you all can offer
are extremely helpful because right.
We do have this proliferation
of news sources, many of many,
most of which are high quality and
are credible. Um, and so, you know,
to the extent that we're highlighting
those and we're training people over time
as,
as they become more and more use to
searching and as they increasingly rely on
Google, right. For everything. In
their lives, the more, the more,
the better they can get a distinguishing
between high and low quality.
Um, it's going to be really
important. Had a quick question
about, uh, the, uh, polarization data
that you showed at the beginning.
Especially, you know, that climate
change chart is very striking. Uh,
and it's easy to read that as the same
cohort if people changing their minds
over time.
But the set of adults voting
Republicans is not the same.
In 2014,
I myself shifted from one of those lines
to another one and [inaudible] taking
my climate change beliefs
with me partially because
I felt more comfortable on
the other line with my current
set of climate change beliefs. Uh,
and so do you have a feeling for how
much of this is people changing minds and
how much of this is mines
shifting their identification?
Uh, that's a great question. I
mean, so, so given the polarization,
given polarization of politics today,
you see for most people write
a strengthening of, of party
attachment and, and, um,
uh, people are less likely to, to switch
sides and this, and this is interesting.
Um, yeah, I mean, so the,
the question whenever it,
whenever you see partisan changes
like that, like the ones I showed,
it always comes down to this question of
is it persuasion or replacement? Right?
Are People, people forming new
coalitions? Um, in the case,
in the case of climate change mean climate
change has just become so politicized
and how it's how it's communicated in,
in media that it,
it sort of is a political issue now.
It's almost covered as a political
issue in a sort of left versus right
framework as opposed to a scientific
framework that other issues are,
are disgusting. Um, so yeah, I mean, I,
it's hard for me to imagine a lot of,
um,
within party persuasion now on that issue.
Right?
My sense would be that it's mostly,
it's mostly people,
people moving to a Gi tend to
adjust their views with their party
in general.
In general,
the evidence suggests that people do go
along with their party on these kinds of
cues. Right? I mean, if you
think about it, right? You know,
in the seventies and eighties,
the idea that it was somehow part isn't
what you thought about the climate with
preposterous that wasn't on anyone's
agenda whatsoever, right? And,
but the set of elite cues that people
were getting started to diverge,
and then we saw this kind of tribalistic
movement along those lines and people
falling, right? There are those folks
who might switch lines as you suggest,
but I'd say far more just,
you know,
they just to extend that they've
thought about climate change,
they're taking cues from people they
trust as to what they should believe.
If you think about how most people write
form opinions on most issues, right?
Most, most people on most issues are not
very informed enough, very interested.
And so it's a really easy heuristic
to use if people, right. If,
if, if the media just presents an
issue as, as a left versus right issue,
it's a very easy cue for people to take
as opposed to engaging in war effort,
fall sort of info search
about global warming. Right?
And you just go to your team.
Yeah.
Hi. Um, my question's around
you, you presented kind of some,
some findings of how people
are discovering, uh, fake news,
whether it's from search or social media,
but has there been any work that kind of
understands how they make it into those
environments ranging because I mean,
things get created and there
must be some strategies or,
or maybe common attributes that help
these things get very wide distribution
because these things don't get widely
distributed if just if they were just
graded. There must be some
strategies that, that, that might,
some patterns that are emerging.
And I was wondering if you had thoughts
or there's some research that's on this
particular topic.
The mechanism we know best is,
is the seeding of these fake news
articles into Facebook groups.
Um,
you know,
as you guys know about a lot of answers
don't write Facebook is orders of
magnitude larger than Twitter. It's the
most important traffic driver of, of,
of news audiences, online, bar none.
And so it seems like
that was where people,
how people were getting
from social media to, uh,
to the fake news sites
was the seating happened.
And that was starting a diffusion process.
Now again,
it's important to think about this,
like this is a very skewed distribution,
right? There's a very large number of fake
news articles that almost no one read.
And if you go to these fake news sites,
there's tons and tons of these.
They were really mass produced in
a very slipshod way. And you know,
any kind of monkeys on typewriters,
fashion,
every so often they hit on a big one.
Right?
And that one went hugely viral and
seems to have disseminated often via
primarily via social media. But that's
certainly not the only thing is you can,
as you can see here,
follow up on that one. Um, you've been,
I think scrupulously neutral about, you
know, the source of this stuff, you know,
is it stops just out there and
the Darwinian sense, you know,
some of this seems to,
you know,
get viral and take off just because
it resonates with people or is there
something more purposeful going
on, whether it's, you know,
particular groups that have,
you know, particular agendas,
state actors, whatever.
Do you study that?
So the state actor part is hard
to assess. Um, I, you know,
you should ask the intelligence community,
um,
the reporting on fake news specifically
right now suggest a more decentralized
process where people were being
attracted largely by the profit motive.
In some cases they might have
ideological partisan motives as well,
but there's very little evidence of, of,
of kind of coordinated effort. Right?
So I showed you that FBI agent story,
uh,
earlier the Hillary Clinton investigation,
you died in a murder suicide.
The guy who wrote that was literally
unemployed, living at home,
trying to figure out how to make money.
He's since come forward and
explained his story. Um,
the Macedonian teenagers didn't have to
seem to have any particular ax to grind
as far as anyone can tell and so forth.
So it's possible there's
coordination or state actors,
some of those other kinds of
state sponsored misinformation
online we can talk
about.
But in terms of the,
the set of sites that were being
widely distributed during the campaign,
I think it's fair to say that there's
not a lot of hard evidence of the record
of that at this point.
So,
so journalists are constantly thinking
about how they can rewrite headlines or
taglines to get to make
their content real news.
We like to call it a go viral.
Um,
were there particular
headline structures or, um,
pictures added or structures to specific
Facebook posts that kind of stood out
in a common thread for
these posts that went viral?
I mean, I would say the common thread
was mostly Hillary is evil, right?
If you had to boil it down to three words,
um,
but there were certainly lots of stories
like that that didn't resonate. Um,
it does seem to have something
of a Darwinian feel to it.
Like there's lots and lots
and lots of other, uh,
articles that say Hillary is evil that
didn't take off. And for whatever reason,
these resonated.
These five examples aren't the best.
But some of these are kind of in a way
that Parsons might enjoy laughing and
being like, ha ha ha, look, you know,
I don't really believe this bill.
Look how funny it is.
Right?
So one of the most widely shared pro
Clinton fake news stories said Ireland is
taking a political asylum. Refugees
from the United States because of Trump.
Right.
And so how many people were sharing
that because they actually believed it?
How many were sharing?
It is a kind of expression of
anti-Trump feelings or identity, right.
Is less clear. Um,
another one from online.
So if raw fact checking
doesn't convince people, uh,
and might even reinforce false beliefs,
are there any strategies we have
evidence for that do work? You know,
there is, there is evidence in fact
checking works right? So I don't want to,
I don't want to be totally pessimistic
here and say that this problem isn't,
isn't solvable under, under
any conditions. I mean, so, um,
there's a lot of experimental
work now looking at the, uh,
the influence of information
from nonpartisan fact
checking organizations like
politifact and, um, uh, politik
track and other, other organizations,
um, uh, when it comes to, but when
it goes outside of that framework,
when it comes to just kind of watchdog
journalism and trying to correct
misperceptions and more
widely read formats, um, yeah,
there are all sorts of best practices
that, that people can engage it.
And I'm so one of the most widely studied
ones that I would just point out as as
one example. Um, is it people,
people are really bad at processing
negations of planes. Okay.
So Brendan's written written on
this. Um, and, uh, people, uh,
over time tend to remember information.
Uh,
if you tell someone
that something is false,
they tend to remember the
information over time,
but they often forget that it's
false, right? So this is an illusion.
It's called the illusion of
truth, the fact, right? So
you might correct something,
it might,
you know,
might change their factual beliefs
that at the point of the correction,
but then over time people
are bad at processing, uh,
cognitively that things are not true,
right?
And so they might come to actually
hold that belief more over time.
So avoiding negations and framing things
in the affirmative, right? So the,
the classic example of this
from recent years is, um,
Obama is a Christian versus
Obama is not a Muslim.
People just become, uh, especially
when they're motivated, right?
Like they might be with that when people,
people are oftentimes susceptible
to losing sight of, of,
of litigation over time.
And unfortunately that's
all we have time for.
Thank you so much for
coming to [inaudible].
Okay.